letztes mal haben wir nachgefragt welche
sprache ist die schönste in der ganzen
welt und heute fragen wir welches land
ist das schönste in der welt los geht's
[Musik]
was ist dein lieblings lang mein
lieblingsland ist neuseeland und warum
weil ich die menschen sehr nett finde
sehr progressiv was die gesellschaft
angeht eigene erfahrung ich war drei
monate dort deswegen konnte ich das gut
kennenlernen und hab sehr schätzen
gelernt
italien und warum und wie oft versuchen
sie wird alle zwei drei jahre im schnitt
zu und lernen sie italienisch nein mein
lieblingsland mein lieblingsland ich
muss schon mal nachdenken dürfen spanien
und warum spanien weil ich da freunde
haben weil das mehr ist schönes wetter
nette menschen gutes essen und schnell
erreichbar
aber sie kommen doch aus deutschland
also näher dann geht das nicht welche
welches land außer deutschland er war da
gibt es so viele regionen die ich auf
der welt sehr schön finde viele finden
sich in asien wieder aber es kann
genauso gut von landschaftlichen her
kalifornien zum beispiel sein aber wenn
wir jetzt nach asien schauen würden wenn
ich zum beispiel korea japan china
extrem schön interessante länder
natürlich jetzt in deutschland ist
deutschland das lied
das land aber sie kommen doch aus
deutschland oder nicht ich komme aus
finnland ok und warum mögen sie
deutschland in deutschland gibt es vor
allem in berlin gibt es menschen aus
unterschiedlichen kulturen aus ganz
verschiedenen gebieten aber auch ganz
verschiedene bieten deutschland selbst
das ist eigentlich sehr schön italien
und warum warum weil ich das mal gelebt
habe weil ich das essen mag weil ich das
wetter mag aber nicht zum leben er zum
urlaub machen und darum nicht zum leben
so viel chaos zu laut und organisiert
nicht so wie die italiener sind so sich
auf draußen italien und warum weil er
meine frau herkommt in welches land ist
ihr lieblings mein lieblingsland
das lieblingsland deutschland meine auch
ich komme aus polen und ich mag es in
deutschland ja und ganz viele leute
sagen auch italien viele leute mögen in
italien sie sagen aber zum urlaubmachen
nicht zum leben
ok ja ich bin eigentlich sicher
diejenigen kann ich ja sagen haben
bestätigen leider aber ein schönes land
auf jeden fall ich also ich komme nicht
aus deutschland befinde sich deutschland
am besten genau so wie ich ich kann mir
aus polen und sehe das ist holländer
machen ja viel urlaub im ausland
welches land ist ihr lieblingsland
deutschland natürlich und warum das
nicht gut kenne
aber es gibt immer noch neue sachen zu
entdecken groß und nähe
ja stimmt und freundlich leute ja aber
das kennt man ihn also holländer sind
schon extrem schottland das ist toll
weil ich fahre morgen nach schottland
nämlich verbringen der neun tage urlaub
deshalb können sie mir erzählen warum
schottland tal ist es gibt ganz tolle
abgelegene natur einfach es ist ruhig es
ist nicht so warm
wir wissen jetzt schon dass es jeden tag
regnen wird
gut dass wir in spanien aber schlimmer
erscheint nicht wegen des wetters fährt
man ja nicht nach schottland geht und
wer was kann man im schatten land noch
machen bis bezwingen das werde ich
ausprobieren mit sicherheit und essen
auch ganz gut essen besser als erwartet
wahrscheinlich
und was schätzen sie an italien noch die
freundlichkeit
die schönwetter die umgebung die das die
historie dort die viel erhaltene
gebäude die dort noch vorhanden sind das
schätzen wir hier in deutschland ja
warum
ich liebe berlin
und weil es schön ist und die leute sind
sehr nett als im inland
auch ich liebe auch aber deutschland ist
mein lieblings so was ist mein
lieblingsland mein lieblingsland was ist
mein lieblingsland dänemark und warum
denn immer ich mag die leute die küche
und den kleidungsstil die entspanntheit
die ruhe und in welchem teil von
dänemark bleibst du dann kopenhagen
kommen
wunderschön und warum sprechen sie so
gut deutsch
ich habe länger in deutschland gelebt
und bin immer hin und wieder hier
gewesen und dann hat sich sind wir
erhalten und das ist natürlich ganz
schön es ist wunderschön weil finish
fing ich kann man nicht lernen
nein meine kinder kann nicht sprechen
nein das ist so unglaublich nepal und
warum ich finde es landschaftlich sehr
schön und für mich
mit dem ich in kontakt gekommen
wenn ein paar jahren sehr echt und haben
sie schon und er ist gestiegen nein ja
also deutschland ist ganz gut
frankreichs gefällt mir ganz gut am
atlantik deutschland anderen 90 prima
und was ist speziell ist an frankreich
austern jakobsmuscheln retten
augustin mag ich nicht so sehr guten
roth war nicht so trocken
ja die zeiten bei sommerloch lina und
sprechen sie französisch also welche
städte in italien würdest du uns
empfehlen
am besten nicht die städte am besten
aufs land im süden nach apulien nardo
wo ist der ultimative geheimtipp aber es
ist kein geheimtipp mehr an als es
öffentlich oder so das ist ja
interessant weil es gibt im grunde zwei
italien sind südliche teil nordische
teil sehr verschieden oder ja sehr
verschieden nicht machen norden auch
aber das bündnis berlin ist so
unglaublich ich war in mathe
das ist auch im süden so unglaublich
schön das will man ja nicht glauben
naja und italienisch ist einer der
schönsten sprachen der welt das sicher
und würde ich auch sagen wünsche als
österreich ja hübsch aus österreich und
hübsch aus
deutsch also sage ich schon deutschland
agieren wollen welches land das ich
liebe spanien und warum mentalität sonne
und was nur israel israel das ist
interessant waren sie schon öfters ins
leider habe ich es nicht geschafft ist
aber mein nächstes reiseziel
wo kommen sie her und welches land ist
ihr lieblingsland das ist eine
schwierige frage im moment
berlin in deutschland
und welches land es euer lieblings land
schreibt es uns fleißig in den
kommentaren und werdet mitglied bei
unserem projekt dann könnt ihr auch
interaktive übungen bekommen und
transkripte und besten dank und bis zum
nächsten mal
[Musik]